great question um it's kind of like
asking like i want to get into shape
where should i start it's like i can
give you a long list it doesn't really
matter where you start just start
um
uh we already talked about great leaders
or students of leadership you know what
how is your how's your how's your
journey you know do you watch the talks
read the books all the things like that
who's your leadership buddy somebody who
who's sort of willing to call you out
when something goes goes a little bit
awry or they disagree how'd i do today
was that okay you know to have a an
objective
outsider having a leadership buddy is
really important or a group of folks
that you talked on a regular basis about
it that's huge i have a group of people
that i talked on a regular basis we just
call each other and talk about this
stuff or tell each other things that go
right and things that go wrong the stuff
that i've learned just from them telling
me stuff huge
um empathy practicing that empathy
muscle is a big one right i said it
multiple times before which is trying
very very hard to replace judgment with
curios curiosity catching yourself where
you're immediate like they're an idiot
they screwed up they got it wrong
right to
i wonder what else is going on or i
wonder what happened or let me go on a
fact-finding mission before i come to a
conclusion
right
those are things that are
they're they're they're simple but
they're hard but you can do it tomorrow
the other big one is checking in with
your folks
like having one-on-ones and just being
like how are you like tell me what's
going on like what's going on in your
life
you know and i know especially in a
paramilitary organization machismo guns
you know all of this kind of stuff but
to to have conversations that are a
little bit raw a little bit vulnerable
you know like
people have challenges in their lives
they've got kids who are struggling
they've got kids who've struggling
through covert they've got family who's
sick like all of this stuff comes to
work
you know and having safe spaces and just
checking in with people one of the best
chiefs that i know every year he does a
listing tour of his whole organization
you could just do it for your team
we his hour-long one-on-one
conversations just to listen not solve
anything
what can you know how is it going how is
your how is the job what can we do
better and he just listens and it's this
hugely cathartic experience but he gets
tremendous amounts of learning about
what he can do better and what the
organization can do better and just
knowing his people like the names of
their spouses the name of their kids
things like that make people feel seen
and heard you could do that tomorrow